[Musique]
mais
christine de mazières bonjour merci
d'être sur le plateau de tv 78 pour ce
vip que l'on va vous consacrez vous êtes
ici parce que vous êtes évinoise et vous
venez de sortir un roman
votre premier roman qui s'appelle trois
jours à berlin
voilà aux éditions sabine wespieser
donc c'est pour ça que vous êtes ici
pour que l'on en parle déjà aux affaires
un peu plus connaissance avec vous vous
êtes franco allemande
oui et vous êtes de père ou de mère
allemande ma mère est allemande et je
suis né en france
vous êtes né en france vous avez vécu en
allemagne j'ai passé toutes mes vacances
d'été d'accord j'y vais très souvent et
vous avez toujours très souvent et vous
étiez à l'est ou à l'ouest alors mais
mes parents mais ma mère était à l ouest
bien sûr sinon je ne serais pas là mais
au bord du mur
ah oui d'accord au coeur du noeud de ce
roman finalement quasiment quasiment
alors professionnellement vous êtes
magistrats et vous avez travaillé dix
ans pour le syndicat et des mois
national de l'édition
voilà c'est les éditeurs en fait c'est
ça leur organisme professionnel
non et c'était votre votre métier et là
vous êtes magistrats et vous êtes donc
mis à l'écriture d'un roman comment ça
faisait longtemps que vous en aviez
envie comment c'est venu ce moment oui
j'aime beaucoup écrire depuis depuis
l'enfance et puis j'ai une carrière qui
m'a pas laissé le temps
et voilà on arrive ans déjà avec un peu
le milieu de la vie on serait peut-être
que la vocation rentrée les importantes
qu'elles s'expriment et je me suis mise
à écrire et effectivement si mon premier
roman et vous avez démarré tout de suite
avec ce livre la wii avec cette écriture
d'accord et vous ai mis longtemps à
l'excès j'ai mis deux ans à peu près
d'accord il sujet il mijotait dans un
coin de votre tête depuis longtemps ou
fait j'ai vu comme ça j'avais plein de
sujets j'ai crié j'ai écrit en parallèle
d'autres d'autres textes mais celui-ci
effectivement il plonge dans ma
dans ma vie dans ma biographie parce que
la division de l'allemagne m'a beaucoup
touché depuis depuis donc tout petit de
par mes expériences aussi dans ma
famille oui et ce que j'ai trouvé
absolument fascinant c'est que la chute
du mur de berlin en fait c'est un
événement absolument magistral mais qui
n'a été décidé et finalement par
personne c'est des sortes d'actes
manqués et je trouve c'est une ruse de
l'histoire extraordinaire et j'avais
envie de raconter déjà cet enchaînement
étonnant qui a conduit cette révolution
pacifique parce que pas une seule goutte
de sang a été versé alors que tout le
monde était surarmés connaît le mur
c'est quand même encore des des gens
tués pour avoir essayé de franchir une
ligne 89 délicate donc c'était quelque
chose quand même de tête de terribles
quand la balle et franchissez dans
d'autres endroits s'est terminée par des
bains de sang roumanie et la berlin non
et ça c'est la naissance de cette cette
idée de raconter cette histoire et après
se sont greffés une multitude de
personnages pour donner tous les points
de vue voilà ce que dit alors de gens
qui étaient pour le mur qui étaient
contre j'ai voulu donner une vision
multi facettes très large c'est alors
qu'on a une française anna qui a connu
quelqu'un à l'est qui a très envie de
retrouver une amie chat qui donc à l'est
qui vialette
on a faim il ya une multitude de
personnages moi j'avais envie de dire
cinq ou six mais finalement il y en a
une quinzaine mais en fait c'est
tellement tellement fluide cc on réalise
pas qu'il ya autant de personnages
trouvent c'est vrai il ya les principaux
puis après les autres qu'ils apportent
leur petite touche et et puis aussi
l'ange castiel l'ange des larmes qui est
donc issu du d'un film de wismes vendeur
oui absolument a compté mois comment
vous avez eu l'idée de rajouter ce
personnage eh bien j'avais commencé ce
roman choral c'est à dire qu'il ya une
quinzaine de narrateur différent là et
pour les scènes
de collective ou le temps les allemands
de l'est
al'annonce cette annonce étonnante se
met en marche vers les passages de
frontières donc le peuple en marche
j'avais envie de le raconter mais une
manière là aussi multiples et je me dis
aimer mais qui prend ça j'ai évidemment
c'est des scènes où il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de gens qui font sont des
milliers et sa masse oui le long de
l'année des portes du mur du mur et tout
à coup je sais pas j'ai eu cette idée
parce que j'aime beaucoup le film de wim
wenders qui s'appelle les ailes du désir
qui est paru en 87 week est pas juste a
donc deux ans avant la chute du mur il
quitte un film d'une très grande poésie
qui n'a pas pris une ride bon ou c'est
vraiment un chef-d'oeuvre qu'on peut
revoir en permanence avec beaucoup de ce
que c'est c'est en plus un texte écrit
par un écrivain
peter handke et c'est trés intemporel
cette histoire de deux anges qui plane
au-dessus des 2 de berlin divisé dont
love par amour d'une femme va devenir
plus même en images mais l'autre qui est
qu'à ciel qui est donc l'enjeu des
larmes
il va rester anges donc j'ai pris
finalement le parti de prendre comme
l'un des narrateurs cet ange cassiel en
me disant que c'est merveilleux parce
que se met dans la peau de cet ange qui
traverse en fait les consciences et qui
équivalent de toutes parts ça me permet
de rendre compte encore plus divisent je
vois risque pardon je vais couper on a
l'impression que boyet où il est
au-dessu quoi comme un drone finalement
il peut aller partout ça donne une
vision globale de l'ensemble quand même
peut-être été compliqué à réaliser
exactement qui refuse et surplomb de
l'histoire à la csii avec bienveillance
d'accord d'accord alors en lisant ce
roman cake événement passionnant donc
c'est a subi une dure à dire une unité
de temps très courte donc c'est vraiment
ça d'aimables de presque 9 novembre jour
où comme vous dites c'est presque cot
cot le personnage de la stasi fellah
l'annnonce de l'ouverture du mur et que
la journaliste dit mais quand il sait
pas ce qu'il doit répondre et du bord
allez maintenant te fait prier aux lives
in devant saint cloud chez moi j'ai même
vu de bonnes soirées
hallucinant et du coup les gens enfin
c'est ce que vous racontez petit à petit
très paisiblement vont aller moi de quoi
il retourne en promettant en passant le
mur et en promettant de rentrer le soir
afin de rentrer ce qu'ils font
d'ailleurs très disciplinés d'ailleurs
très discipliné c'est ce que je trouve
aussi facilement dans votre roman
c'est qu'on comprend c'est la vie
complètement inhumaine qui savent f
vous pouvez nous décrire un peu la stasi
les espions vous avez connu vous des
gens de l'est qui ont suivi sa tout à
fait oui mais j'ai en fait j'ai
découvert que j'avais des cousins à
l'est lorsque j'avais 10 ans j'ai
commencé une correspondance avec une
cousine du même âge et puis lorsque
j'étais étudiante en sciences politiques
je me suis dit il faut peut-être aller
de l'autre côté du mur parce que c'est
intéressant d'aller voir cette autre
europe
monsieur on était en 85 et j'avais 19
ans et avec une amie sac à dos carte
interrail le savoir tous les pays de
l'est
il a devancé par ailleurs d un ananas et
vous alors non non c'est pas moi puisque
cette danse français alors voilà le
personnage français en fait n'a aucune
origine allemande
donc c'est pas moi voilà mais c'est son
écriture avec des mélanges de choses
quoi va pas dans les ai coupés dans les
cuisines et donc j'ai effectivement j'ai
vu ce régime
déjà nos lettres et été ouverte ce qu'on
envoyait étaient en général prélevés on
était surveillée ont été fouillés on
devait aller tous les jours à la police
en fait pour se présenter lorsque rt
surveiller
lorsque nous jeunes
jeune étudiante un peu fauchés quand
même on allait à l'auberge de jeunesse
on n'avait pas le droit parce qu'on est
capitaliste donc il fallait absolument
et dans un hôtel et puis ensuite quand
le mur est tombé
en fait j'écris un essai qu un livre
d'entretien avec le dernier chef des
gourmands derrière des airs qui
s'appelle lothar de maizière
alors c'est un quasi quasi cousin
homonyme et est donc c'est lui qui est
en marche 90 a été lors des premières
élections libres en allemagne de l'est a
été élu pour faire la réunification dont
six en six mois et là bas et donc à
travers lui que je vois toujours que
j'aime beaucoup
j'ai aussi appris à connaître beaucoup
ce vécu des allemands de l'est cela
derrière et qui me disait et lorsqu'on
était plus de 3 on était sûr qu'il y
aurait un rapport
voilà cela sur la réunion et dans leurs
mots que même un couple peu s'espionner
mutuellement
absolument voilà c'est pour une société
total et vous avez écrit
c'est depuis la crèche ils ont appris à
obéir se taire point barre ce sont des
âmes mortes
vous parlez d'un monde en noir et blanc
et d'amandes en couleurs face et on a
besoin que c'était pire que la russie
finalement c'est difficile à dire mais
c'est un une société collection d'oeufs
de raie de la surveillance l'état
est-allemand
avec thé quand même obligé de construire
un mur en pour empêcher les gens de
s'enfuir donc c'est dire que c'était pas
c'était pas très c'était pas une société
qui doit l'être humain déjà rites qui
tenait au sol elle avait besoin de se
protéger
alors aujourd'hui on entend beaucoup de
shows de nostalgie en disant mais quand
même c'était pas mal il y avait les
crèches les adresses des plus jeune âge
merci donc voilà c'est ça tout à fait et
la dernière phrase parce qu'il y en a
plein de très jolies phrases que j'avais
envie de citer mon va pas avoir le temps
la dernière phase des voix le rire mais
le personnage pour la première fois
sourit vous vous c'est ça moi qui m'a le
plus parler ces visages et ne vont te
regarde pas dans les yeux on ne sourit
pas c'est un espèce de cette ouverture
c'était un retour à l'humanité et
finalement alors un gars est bien sûr
une humanité en domaine de
l'investissement alors c'est très
difficile pour les personnes qui ont
vécu à led qui disent aujourd'hui mais
nous on est enfin on a quand même une
vie mais bien sûr pour
et donc on peut pas on peut pas donc
jeter toute notre vie d'avant ça te
caraquet et donc ils vivaient on
appelait ça la société de niche
danis michaud gesellschaft ça veut dire
que on en fait on vivait dans les tout
petits cercles de repli on se repliait
avec quelques personnes dans laquelle on
avait vraiment confiance mais parfois
cette confiance a été trahie quand même
parce que les gens après coup quand les
archives la stasi ont été ouvertes ont
découvert des choses affreuses et
apports d'espionnage au mythe dont il
n'a jamais jamais donc ça c'est
absolument t'aimer mais quand même on se
replier dans l'ain team et c'est pour ça
qu'il y avait aussi une vie
intellectuelle énorme on lisait beaucoup
à la fin la lecture est large il y avait
quand même des on essayait de de survie
dans les interstices de cette société
trouver des failles et puis avec les
gens qui croyaient à 200 % après été
bougé il y avait quelques personnages de
man qui sont membres du politburo qui
sont qui sont parmi les classes
dirigeantes dans cet ouvrage et qui
explique que en fait c'était un mal pour
un bien finalement c'était vous fallait
passer par cette phase un peu compliqué
de restriction liberté pour ensuite
arriver la société parfaite d'accord
donc y avait des gens qui croyaient et
parler des migrations intérieures à
l'émigré sujet ça intérieur tout à fait
son fond de soi et entre entre soi voilà
écoutez ce livre il est absolument
fascinant très très joliment écrit c'est
très fluide c'est très agréable à lire
et donc bravo et merci et vous avez des
projets d'autres livres oui j'aime bien
sûr alors qu'on parle ou pas on doit
évidemment c'est la fin en fait j'ai
plusieurs textes que je que je suis en
train d'écrire et un peu trop tôt pour
en parler pour parler des thèmes
quand vous écrivez un exter début de
romance de vous jeter des idées pour
après le développer ou pas en fait j'ai
énormément de début de deux romans la
gp2 textes qui sont déjà assez assez
avancé donc la corde en parallèle soir
d'être débouché sur un vrai roman parce
qu'en fait on j'écris sans avoir de plan
préconçu etc les personnages ensuite
situations qui s'impose ça dépend
comment faire d'une succursale axa mûri
tout cela est donc je ne sais pas encore
ce qui peut advenir qu'elle à massy
sortir très bien et je me disais une
petite question comme ça d'avoir le nom
d'un homme politique connu
vous êtes pas dit un jour ça va me
freiner ou par rapport à ce que vous
allez écrire dans vos romans
non pas du tout a dit ou pas du tout non
non non non je me suis pas posé la
question d'avoir de me prendre un
pseudonyme
ouais vous attendent je ne faisais que
je vous lance de thomson je m'attache
partiel voilà et pas continuer comme ça
en tout cas merci beaucoup christine de
mazières
et puis on pourra vous retrouver dans
certaines librairies pour des signatures
enfin on mettra tout ça sur l'écran
voilà mais messi a très vite j'ai fait
merci
[Musique]